hi everyone i'm alan and welcome to my
channel with today my microphone is
taking up
uh probably 50 of my screen just how we
like it
i got this beautiful box from microsoft
that
well it says game pass on it but i
believe
that this box will give me access to
xcloud
xbox knew that i did not have an android
phone
um i don't have an android tablet the
ios ecosystem has certainly sucked me in
so they sent me this box so that i can
get hands on time with xcloud
um though i will say i did agree and
signed a thing saying that i would
return it after coverage purposes
and if you're new here i guess uh you
probably don't know that i am very
interested in streaming tech
basically anything that i see as an
advancement of the games industry i am
almost immediately
very interested in you know it's the
industry i've shaped my entire life
around
literally left my home country for it
and that and i have had
positive experiences with stadia and
that it runs quite well for me i don't
like their current
subscription and purchase model i think
that that's a disaster
i get that stadia doesn't work for a lot
of people but my experience has been
quite smooth and actually quite cool
getting to play destiny just on the go
uh is a novelty that still hasn't worn
off on me and i do have concerns where
game streaming is concerned
that's too many times to say concerned
in one sentence i do have a video about
that
already which i can link if you're
interested but a lot of my issues are
with potential implications
uh or the potential ultimately to put
more advertising in games to make you
watch an ad before you get to watch a
cutscene
or even to manipulate things live to
make people play for longer
anyway that's how i feel about game
streaming giving you that context so
that you know that i'm really excited to
try
out xcloud on android it's not something
that i even think i'll use very much i
have a great pc
i have a really solid setup of consoles
at home
i do play my switch on the go but um i
think the potential
is is very fascinating so let's open up
this beautiful box shall we okay
oh oh oh she fancy okay well microphone
you know you just need to chill a bit
okay we got a box to open first up just
a little game pass slip i guess this is
gonna give me
oh slap my keyboard this is going to
give me access to game pass
on the samsung galaxy store on my note
20. i also got
well i want to show you him [ __ ]
jesus christ
oh heck what have i done oh my gosh this
is what the box looks like
this is the worst unboxing i've ever
done it's the issue is my microphone
just like won't
stay up like it won't so usually i would
have it much lower but because it's just
not staying
this is kind of the only place it [ __ ]
we have
this little xbox token which also has a
12 month xbox game pass
ultimate membership code on it very cute
another
game pass box oh okay this
is going to be a razer kishi xbox
launch edition the razer kishi
is a universal mobile gaming controller
for android designed for xbox apparently
also includes four days ultimate they're
really throwing it out how do you plan
to make money off of this
microsoft if you throw out a million
codes at every step
so i guess here's what it's gonna look
like what are you
is this contraption phone holding situ
oh my gosh
okay here we have the note 20 5g
it's got a pen i love pants and just to
get
everything else out of here we also have
a game pass power brick
this is also samsung i like it
and then just your connected cable and
now the box
is empty let's open up this headphone
shall we
this is going to be cool i'm i'm
actually excited for something to do
with
playing a video game on a mobile phone
who'd have thought
so here's the phone you know there you
go that's what that's what my camera
setup looks like
the light is too small and that's why my
face always looks terribly poorly lit
so now you're seeing how it looks on the
inside obviously this is the note 25g
um i could compare it to my iphone for
anyone who happens to be curious
my dirty ass iphone uh samsung is
significantly bigger which i feel like
appeals to me when it comes to playing
video games
good stuff love a cable and then there's
this other tiny box that has
nothing in it just a tiny box okay you
do you tiny box
all right looks like i have to let it
charge for a little bit and then i will
be back
all right hey everyone new camera angle
so i got all the cool phone
setup stuff done um and downloaded the
game pass app
okay that is me
okay
this is exciting oh i do have to clip
the controller okay
okay this is actually pretty cool it
feels
very plasticky which i guess is ideal
for what it weighs
but um i didn't realize it was like a
fully game boss branded controller
that's done pop that out
i guess yeah whoa
cool what that's actually pretty neat
okay
we're gonna put the phone in the middle
okay so even on the startup street
screen here
we are getting some minor hiccups but
nothing major
let's do it
it looks really good like like i
genuinely uh so drifty forgot about you
this is literally my favorite car of a
pagani zonda
um but yeah it's like
maybe like a tiny bit grainy but
imperceptibly when it's this small
okay like even when we're like going
through particles
now let me try another hedge
i'm gonna go let's do battle tones
this is obviously a loading screen worth
noting is in beta i do also want to note
you know i have an iphone um this does
not work if you didn't already know for
anyone who's on ios
which is absolutely apple's fault rather
than microsoft's fault
but it's worth noting it doesn't work um
also isn't available in a lot of
countries just yet
it's not available in australia my home
country so there are still some pretty
significant limitations
uh internet is so unstable in australia
that it kind of
would surprise me if it ran in the first
place honestly
okay let's do it
i mean this is promising so far not that
we've seen much yet
all right let me fight someone
so for the record um for anyone who
doesn't know this game might be like a
weird one to showcase
because uh uh it does intentionally look
choppy um
because of the art style it made it look
like an 80s cartoon but that is an
intentional thing but i can tell you
that you know my experience finishing
battle toads
this looks perfect this is running
perfectly i have absolutely zero
complaints about this at all
[Music]
okay okay this feels way too heavy
um definitely worth noting obviously i'm
not used to playing video games
while holding a screen in my hand
um i'm gonna do
master chief collection let's test that
out shall we
wait what why is that in a different
language i don't know how i did that
i would not like to cancel thank you i'm
okay
i feel like the response time is pretty
much perfect
maybe not 100 of the time but um okay
let's go if we go campaigns
i'm gonna go reach uh
missions we'll go
nightfall is what i believe i'm up to in
this playthrough i think
yeah yeah let's do it
love playing on heroic i'll leave the
skulls off because why not
let's go
yeah that's fine
oh my god i just can't believe this
functions
it just it just seems insane i'll
definitely say that i can't see very
clearly
already camera setup number three my
camera just died
um but i have played a little bit more
of halo there you go video section
you know i've used stadia and had a
positive experience with stadia even
when a lot of people were having very
negative experiences with stadia
my internet connection is far so this
runs to me i am not going to tell you
that game pass
um or xcloud on on your phone is
definitely going to work for you
just got a headshot nice work i i i
think that part of what i've said about
stadia in the past comes from
i had expectations of it being very very
bad um okay i just got some choppiness
there with a drop ship coming in
but majority of the time is just i
expect i expect some bad
uh and yeah that made me a little bit
more lenient with stadia potentially was
that i
i almost didn't expect it to function at
all so i was like oh my god it runs for
me
yeah okay this is choppy for me right
now like for the most part
just very very easy to jump into um sure
there's a loading screen to launch the
app
or to launch games yeah i don't know
what else to say i had to play with the
sensitivity and i had to play with the
the brightness for sure it needed to be
a lot brighter especially considering my
mobile phone is obviously extremely
glary
so playing this particularly dark level
in uh halo reach that was a very good
headshot
uh was pretty much intolerable and
obviously for people who
do have android phones who might be
playstation users
who don't uh
generally have access to xbox game pass
it's so cheap
and you now get to play every xbox
exclusive
for almost no money on your phone i mean
look i played the entirety of breath of
the wild
on switch handhelds the whole thing um
if they can get the controller setups
right and make them feel as nice
as the joy-con do then i
probably would play through an entire
game like this
um you know if i want to just lay in bed
and not look at a tv for some reason
like this is enjoyable enough that i'm
having trouble finishing this video
because i just want to keep playing halo
you know what i'm saying
and it's in beta like you did the right
move by launching this thing in beta
rather than launching it
as a full release with a subscription
and
making people pay for it um of course
like i said earlier only available on
android i'm only able to play it because
microsoft loaned me this phone
uh i am generally on ios which means i
actually am
not able to play it only available in
certain countries uh
couldn't play it if i was home in
australia so there are definitely still
limitations um
that hopefully there's some resolution
can be found for but
do want to say halo specifically has
been choppier than the other ones but
man very very very cool tech
all right everyone um yeah obviously
this is just a quick impressions video
if you guys have any questions or you
want me to make more content of this if
you'd like to see more of it totally
happy to do that too
but of course it's in beta it's
available to all of you as well so i
don't have to show it to you
you can check it out for yourself as
long as you have an android and that is
it for me today everyone i'm alana i'll
see you guys next time bye